we have this uh story
i said we're gonna talk about it we got
this from cnn scientists slam joe
rogan's podcast episode with jordan
peterson as absurd and dangerous absurd
absurd what are they talking about i was
the greatest podcast ever i was
listening to some of it i'm saving it
because i'm going on a trip this weekend
so i was like i want to be able to
listen to the full four hours but jordan
peterson really does does say absurd you
know that kind of like
but uh anyway
that's neither here nor there uh uh this
segment is not about cnn complaining
about joe rogan's podcast it's about joe
rogan's basically the new york times
i've talked about this before setting
the news cycle what is the story we
should be talking about the new york
times above the fold front page news
story ukraine invasion russia ghost
are we talking about whatever it is that
new york times cares about not really
we're talking about what jordan peterson
and and joe rogan want to talk about
joe did i said jordan pierce before joe
rogan is effectively be you said joe
rogan i said jorgen he's become the new
york times so when cnn is like
scientists are are upset at joe rogan's
podcast over his story joe has just
gotten them
to talk about climate change and now
here we are addressing the issue joe
rogan's been in the news cycle non-stop
for like what now months yeah over the
guests he's been having and it's in with
increasing frequency check this out
first you have cnn
joe rogan and jordan peterson we have
the verge spotify can't afford to lose
joe rogan now it's not even about neil
young anymore it's just about him we
have this from the independent what is
this one joe rogan podcast guest claims
pandemic is the money grab and they're
trying to kill us once again and that's
it's jordan peterson
so so
what i see here is look man you know
we're we're effectively becoming the joe
rogan review podcast i'm going to talk
about this but to be honest we were the
cnn review podcast before that we
criticized the media we criticized the
mainstream press the media lies and now
that joe is basically taking over you
know dictation of the news cycle it is
becoming
prominent it is becoming common to
discuss the ideas that he's talking
about in fact so prominent i believe i
could be wrong but i believe the 13th
biggest podcast in the us is the joe
rogan experience review
whoa yeah it's like some guys talking
about what joe rogan talked about wow
yeah is he the number one joe rogan
isn't on uh
uh itunes anymore oh yeah spotify so he
of course he's number one on spotify
right never moving but uh on on on
itunes i think it's number 13 is the joe
rogan review
podcast so this is so interesting to me
and watching the mainstream media try to
slam podcast is like this huge source of
miss and disinformation it's really
intriguing to me because it looks like
they're starting to wake up to the fact
that joe rogan is in fact calling the
shots like you're you are saying he is
in fact controlling the narrative he's
making them talk about this one thing
that he wants to talk about and whether
they realize it or not they're very much
responding to exactly what he's doing
which if you were a very clever person
i'm sure he could use exactly to his
advantage and you're right i do think
that should give us a lot of hope as far
as the right is concerned i think that
this means that the media is kind of
starting to pay attention to the right
starting to hopefully perhaps maybe
cater to the right not that we really
necessarily want them to but it's
definitely a factor and things are
definitely shifting so perhaps the tide
is turning i was i was right real quick
just pulling oh yeah yeah i've got the
itunes top charts joe rogan experience
review podcast number 13. and father
mike schmitz is still top 10 with the
bible in a year he was the number one
podcast he was the number one podcast
he's father what a waste he's i hate us
so attractive but that is exactly
priests there are so many look the
priesthood is not just for men who are
not uh attractive if you are an
attractive young man do not think your
vocation would be a waste can you be a
female priest no that's a priestess we
don't have those yeah priestess
catholic church
this is no because i don't think rogan
is i don't consider him on the right at
all and by any means the dude wants like
universal basic income he's super like
kind of left libertarian um but the
anything that's not far left these days
people are like it's it's right because
they're trying to centralize i think
like joe regan i think of him as
independent like i really do and yes
anything that is not marxist is
right-wing yeah but i just think of him
as independent i've mentioned this
before but when uh i
i'm on my first day of college or in the
very at the very least it was the first
class i ever took at college as a local
community college and
this this was in 2013 and my art teacher
recommended the joe rogan experience and
at the time the art teacher was liberal
today he would probably be considered if
he has the same opinions independent or
right wing i remember thinking what is
this like liberal garbage podcast he's
about to recommend me i remember when i
first listened to joe rogan i enjoyed it
but i was like oh yeah this guy's
definitely like on the left but i kind
of want to hear his opinions and now joe
rogan is considered this far right
figure it's so bizarre how quickly that
[ __ ] that's that's i think what happened
to trump because it's like trump don't
that was one reason i was actually a
never trumper in 2016. i
i now am totally ashamed to admit this
please don't hate me i was living in new
york so the vote didn't matter i i wrote
in ben sasse i totally regret my 2016
vote but i was a never trumper till the
end but then in 2020 i proudly voted for
trump but one of the reasons why i was
never trumper was that i thought that
trump wasn't a conservative i was like
this guy donated to hillary clinton
uh he has no track record that i can
look to to suggest that he would do
anything that's conservative um but i
think just by how insanely marxist the
democrat party had become
that's that's who he he was an
independent person uh and he donated to
both sides um but you know i think i was
unwilling to break my
my perception and my bigotry toward this
notion of someone had to have this label
as conservative or liberal
so i was just looking at the the podcast
charts someone had commented on one of
my podcasts and they said
i referred to democrats as city urban
liberal types
and city urban liberal types that's cult
that's right that's true that's cult
they were like did you mean to do that
and i was like oh wow i did not
i love this idea too that alternative
media is dangerous and these podcasters
are dangerous as if it was the
alternative media that lied us into a
20-year long war as if it was
alternative media that refused to
entertain the possibility that this
virus could have been manufactured as if
it was alternative media that was trying
to suppress whistleblowers and remove
people's platforms from them it's so
obvious well don't you know that it was
actually uh joe rogan who ordered that
uh missile strike on abdul ramon oh yeah
oh my gosh do you guys remember that he
was that child 16 year old kid who was
who was killed in a drone strike in uh
in yemen oh my gosh and uh barack obama
was was sitting at his table and it was
uh uh you know his his his uh cabinet
comes in and they're like mr president
we got a child that needs to die and
obama was like uh
joe what do i do and then joe was like
look man look you got you gotta bomb
this kid
and then they smoke some dmt well that's
the insane thing right these people are
such lap dogs for the establishment and
when they say that these podcasts are
threatening we all know what they're
really saying is that they are a threat
to our control i don't know if it's
funny enough for a for for a bit or
whatever but it would be you know the
gag i'm imagining is like the new york
times is researching like the iraq wmds
and joe rogan sitting in the room
and he's like they got they got weapons
he's like he's like smoking and he's
like yo they got weapons of mass
destruction like are you sure dude i'm
so sure and they're like oh they're
gonna do it trump's like you know you
know what i think there was russian
collusion like all of the conspiracy
every story like just joe haven't been
there
those 13 marines who died last august
joe rogan ordered joe biden to drop that
yeah exactly exactly these people are so
dangerous it's so frightening who uh hey
who convinced the american people or
tried to convince the american people
that it was a great idea to uh engage in
literally the largest transfer of wealth
that's ever existed in all of human
history and print trillions of dollars
was that alternative media why is food
so expensive right now joseph joe rogan
joe rogan
joe rogan is on the fed joe rogan he's
he's on the yeah he's he's on the he's
on the fed he's he's in a room chilling
with bezos and bill gates and he just
goes yeah i'm just saying there's too
many people
oh my gosh
remember when that was like
you know what i actually heard that
margaret sanger is an ancestor of joe
rogan oh yeah and i run to the family
what if what you know it's funny like
we're joking about it and the and
obviously the joke is that they they
keep accusing him of being so dangerous
or whatever that we're jokingly tying to
all these things i think that would be
one of the best conspiracies ever that
like joe actually is the leader of the
illuminati and he keeps alex close
because you've got to keep your friends
close but your enemies close
so he keeps alex jones on standby
no one would suspect no he's the foil
they're just like like five years from
now they try to claim that joe was on
the exact opposite side of every issue
that he was actually on because a lot of
people reflect on the past like remember
when joe rogan was like crazy in favor
of the mandates and in the media we were
like that's irresponsible man
that's what they it's remarkable i mean
that's kind of what we're seeing now
when you see these these like you know
that's why i'm critical of bill maher to
a certain degree yeah
because it's like when bill maher came
out and said fouch you can't tell me
what to do it's like fauci said do as
you're told in november of 2020.
and now he's coming out acting like ha
ha i'm defiant it's just like dude
you're not convincing anybody you know
so i'll tell you what'll happen
for one the point of this segment was to
point out that joe owns the news cycle
he could he he could he talks about
with jordan peters and climate change
and all of a sudden that's like the
conversation people are having it's
remarkable because everyone knows he he
owns it so moving forward i think what's
going to happen is with like evangeline
lilly these celebrities they know
they know what's popular
ethan klein our good friend over the h3
podcast you see him coming out and
mocking joe rogan over and over again
and it's just like dude like you're
choosing the losing side of this freedom
free inquiry is winning and all the
smear campaigns and everything they want
to do it just doesn't work
because
what it comes down to is what people
want is authenticity
the people who listen to joe know he's
not a scientist they know he's not a
doctor yeah they know he's not the
smartest guy in the world and you like
you can look at the comments and they're
just like he's just a guy
and and that's what it was with vice
in in the late 2000s in the early 2010s
vice was authentic you you got it
the way it was described is that vice
was like if your bar buddy went to
afghanistan and they'd be talking to you
like a friend about what they
experienced and telling a story as
opposed to a guy in a suit being like
let me tell you as the authority
so that's what joe's embodied regular
dude having conversations with a bunch
of crazy people asking questions and i
got to be honest joe's not even
particularly adversarial he's not yeah
like when he had uh josh's episode we we
you know i ranted about him quite a bit
who insinuated i was all right joe
defended me but
still rather passively and then and then
he tweeted when when people are making
fun of him over his myocarditis segment
with joseph's he said i love the guy and
i'm glad he was able to you know show me
or whatever he's still not particularly
at particularly adversarial so it's it's
i will say it's absurd to me
that the media
is going after him so hard
when joe had had uh he had sanjay gupta
on yep and defended sanjay after the
fact when sanjay wrote an article saying
i was scared joe rogan was going to jump
the tail on his table and throttle my
neck when i brought that up joe was like
come on he's just trying to be funny and
i'm like
i okay sure but i wouldn't give him the
benefit of the doubt i think he
genuinely was scared i mean the dude
admitted he never had a three-hour
conversation with another human being
that's crazy yeah that's crazy how is
that possible i i've been doing a wife
right he called has he gone to school i
think he met like a one-on-one interview
oh interview i think that was what he
was implying but hold on hold on hold on
the doubt here yeah yeah
i i've probably
thousands upon thousands of times i've
had three-hour conversations with tons
of different people who you have i know
outside of this show not science
not normal though most people don't do
that oh come on dude i feel like it is
normal to have a three hour three hours
yeah that's pretty normal yeah i'd be at
my friend's house all the people here if
everyone's like it's totally normal you
guys that's totally normal well so do
you think we're not talking about people
talking about this
hold on hold on carrie thinks it's
normal yeah this thing is not i think
it's completely identical i don't even
talk that much i think it's normal and
do you think it's normal no no but but
hold on like you know we come from very
different backgrounds all of us here
yeah so it may not be a great sampling
but my my story is i'd be uh hanging out
at my friend's house you know on like a
saturday evening or whatever it would be
me and like one or two other people and
we would talk for like five or six hours
while like you know some music was
playing in the background right but
you're not listening the whole time like
people will not fall and then they'll be
like huh or like you're zoned out and
you'll be like looking at something
while they're talking or like there will
be times when no no no no no they're
going at it
listening to each other for three hours
you are you are you are
making up what i just said interpreting
you're sitting for five hours we're
literally sitting here
a group of friends had two or three
people yeah we're sitting in the
backyard and we're talking about space
and time and aliens and we would just
talk for hours i see that too taco bell
we'd sit there for four hours yeah free
refills at my friend's house
i would go to wendy's and i would buy
like 30 bucks worth of wendy's and just
get back that's back with a dollar menu
so i get like 20
49 hearts yeah joe rogan and that
inflation damn yeah exactly i believe 17
years ago and we'd be sitting there on
my friend's couch and it would be me and
maybe one or some other person and we
would just be like
i remember having conversations about
how time could what time is and we're
talking about gravity just having the
exact same kind of conversations that
joe would be having yeah
that was that was normal for me and
politics too yeah i'd be talking about
all this stuff so for me when when he
mentioned like i've never even had a
conversation this long i'm like at some
point in your life at least once you've
never done this i i mean i mentioned
this at home i think it was last night
and i was like this blew my mind i could
not believe that he hadn't had a
conversation that that long but to get
back to your point i think that joe
rogan and the joe rogan fight really
highlights the difference between the
elite and just a regular person and the
elite think that they need that we need
them to tell us what to do and all we
want is someone who's genuine and they
can't get it through their heads they do
not understand that and you know the
fight will never end and that that that
is the actual threat to democracy that
is what the elite mindset is the actual
threat to democracy joe rogan is the
people right he isn't he's the opposite
of the threat to democracy like that
that's what i am so angry about you know
the washington post
motto democracy dies and dark like that
is the most disgusting
that's an evil motto because it is true
like
every article they produce that they
just did a big hit job on the
independent women's forum which was full
of lies uh and and i'm like you you
actually this elite institution which
had a very storied history has become so
corrupt that uh their claims again words
don't matter if you're throwing that
phrase around you actually don't know
what it means it's the people look at
what the washington post does what they
say what they do they say democracy dies
in darkness
we need more darkness yeah exactly
that's what they're doing yeah they did
a hit piece on you they did a hit piece
on a 16 year old boy for no reason
that wasn't even newsworthy yeah it
wasn't even a story what it was about
the company
oh yeah well he he got his do we didn't
get our payout yeah unfortunately
having the washington post right about
you is like slipping outside of a fancy
restaurant you're just like hoping like
all right this might be able to turn
into a lawsuit for me if they go too far
are you guys considering suing them
if i if we were i couldn't tell you but
uh but they basically went after an
organization we have so we have a a
membership group called the independent
women's network and our policy director
hadley uh wrote a it was a form letter
like just a suggestion of a letter you
could write to your kid your um your
school the kids you know if they're
being forced to wear masks very polite
letter just kind of ideas on what to
include in the letter and the washington
post takes it uh and they infiltrated
our group they someone bought a fake
membership and leaked it to the
washington post
and um they're like
uh this you know evil coke back group
because we get some money not i can't
disclose how much but we do get some
money from the coke network but we get
money from a lot of other organizations
but they put it on the front page and
they're like they're trying to spread
misinformation and
basically encourage you know extremism
and violence at school boards and
encourage people to to be riled up and
and tell moms to be uh you know demonic
and i'm obviously uh you know using
flourish words but that's basically what
they were saying because of this very
polite form letter um
and and actually the the letter itself
included studies um that that explicitly
you know very well regarded studies
about the the efficacy and the problems
with mass the story didn't even address
any of the studies all they did was
their their hype properly and just um it
was it was really upsetting
but not surprising well yeah they
usually will address the mandate and not
the
actual
science yeah
no but but to the point earlier we were
talking about uh threat to democracy so
i wrote the piece recently for the new
york post and i was looking at research
about just how bigoted liberals are so
there was a study a poll looking at uh
you know i looked at many polls but this
one looked at college campuses and how
bigoted republican students were versus
democrat students it found that 30
percent of democrats and only 7 percent
of republicans said they would not work
for someone who voted differently from
them
and
and also this polling was done by axios
and generation lab which are not
right-wing organizations
and they also said that only five
percent of republican college students
said they wouldn't befriend someone from
the opposite party versus 37 percent of
democrats
and then republicans
71 percent of democrats said they would
not date someone who was
uh a republican versus thirty one
percent oh they weren't
so sad
oh man that's horrible
i think well it's also interesting
they're bigoted in other ways too there
was a
study which showed that
white liberals
were likely to dumb down their language
when talking to black people in white
conservatives or not yeah that was
really revealing but did it shock you at
all no there was no part of me that read
that and went what i can't believe this
right now
would they would they really do that
this was a big red pill for uh i can't
remember who we were talking to was it
was it batia baby yeah she i think she
was saying that that was the like the
red pill moment for when she read that
was like is if this is true like that's
that says something yeah
it says it and it says it in a
dumbed-down way
yeah because it looks down on you it
thinks that you exist as a pawn for its
political agenda yes yeah thanks for
checking out this segment from the tim
cast irl podcast if you want to watch
live you can check out this channel
monday through friday at 8 pm and don't
forget to smash that like button
subscribe to this channel and if you
want more unfiltered and uncensored
content with all of these guests go to
timcast.com and become a member all of
these guests you know and love in
exclusive segments on our website where
we are unrestricted in what we talk
about so you'll definitely not want to
miss it thanks for hanging out we'll see
you all next time
you